[Music]
but they're in Florida hey you have
monsters in Florida that's amazing
they have monsters that if you were
alone in a room with this thing you die
you don't live that's [ __ ] crazy it
they have monsters Heather's monsters in
the world did you guys know they're
alligators and you can get them in
America I think that's crazy how about
being in iguana and there are alligators
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I feel like
there are probably iguanas in swamps
that like lose their [ __ ] to
alligators you know like like it will be
like yeah man
like the iguanas like man watch out when
you got your girl you bring them around
the alligators alligators [ __ ] Ted
will swoop your [ __ ] up man how do you
compete with them alligators you know
they're too big the biggest hell they
can crunch [ __ ] and swivel them
around and drown them in the swamps
they're [ __ ] straight-up monsters and
they'll steal your [ __ ] man alligators
just watch and laugh as iguanas walk by
look at that mother [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
egg iguana I'll steal your [ __ ] keep
walking don't sleep [ __ ]
that's what alligators say we're not
wanders walked by with their [ __ ] don't
sleep and then blink sideways I don't
give a [ __ ] I know they blink up and
down but they still blink sideways they
have that skin under their eyeball under
their eyes their eyelid that blinks
sideways and even if they don't they do
because that's in my head
[Music]